producer sir
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream where anything can
happen including lint on your shirt
which is not podcast certified and
therefore may collect more lint than
would be ideal
it is um dark horse livestream 133
indeed indeed
which
though it seems prime is not on account
of 19 and 7 having been invented am i
right about that invented
if had they not been
19 and seven were invented in the same
way that sex is assigned at birth
uh so by an obstetrician
that was pretty good that's not bad yeah
all right yeah um
which is to say neither invented nor
signed uh discovered
all right do we know who discovered them
we don't need to i just if we do i want
to be complete about it ah do you
yes no we we do not we do not okay then
it is not
well done yes that you can establish
that
pretty much we don't know that you're
telling the truth but we know that you
at least in principle might know that
you don't know and that's how we got
here uh welcome to the rest of you and
um i am dr brett weinstein this is dr
heather heing rhymes with flying
um still does yes
uh yes always always all right we have
uh we have stuff to do it's wednesday it
is it is wednesday we are here in the
middle of the week because neither last
saturday though nor next saturday uh are
we able to be right here in these seats
uh so we will be coming to you next in
what would that be ten days ten days
from now we'll be back with livestream
134 but right now we're here we won't be
doing a q a today but we will be talking
to you a little bit about uh
jordan peterson and twitter we'll be
talking about uh a new preprint uh about
the efficacy and safety of the vaccines
the mrna vaccines
and some efficacy and safety well that
is in part the point
uh we will be talking about trends uh
trends that we are seeing anecdotally
but seeing no reporting on more
generally
in covet cases and i also wanted to talk
just a little bit about an
observations i made this week following
a line from a book that i am reading
that is
quite uh quite remarkable on which on
which more later
so first though
logistics yes logistics and sponsors and
gratitude and and all of that we are as
ever grateful to all of you who are here
uh for your for your sharing for your
engaging for your remarkable
uh
communications to us and we are we are
sorry that we can respond to so few of
them but we run into people and hear
from people
so very often uh that we are having
conversations that people tune into in
part because it is uh it is one of the
few places that they can actually hear
people talking with honesty and
integrity in ways that sound like how
they would like to be able to be talking
with their own family and friends
and um
and so that is that is what we're trying
to do here yes there are a huge number
of you out there and you don't all agree
which is evident in our conversations
but uh you all agree on something higher
than the particulars you agree on the
desirability of figuring out what is
going on and uh being open about it and
courageous and all that so that's right
there are certainly a number of liberals
in our audience like us
uh who don't abide by the uh the new
woke uh so-called progressivism and a
number of conservatives uh some of whom
we disagree with um on the sort of you
know traditional basis of disagreement
uh with you know conservatives versus
liberals some of which we don't some of
whom we don't uh and it's just there's
all sorts of lines um being crossed
being destroyed being you know
unimportant anymore in light of
uh the
revealed but has always been important
uh nature of actually conversation and
coming together over our shared humanity
and frankly our shared fate on this on
this planet on this
tiny little planet tiny little
gorgeous
somewhat fragile
feistier than you might imagine
but boy do we have some tools us
humanity uh with which we might uh
destroy a lot that we should not be
destroying if we're not careful yeah i
thought you were gonna invoke the other
tools the tools with which we might
rescue ourselves by bootstrapping a new
way but no i was thinking about things
like fracking no no i i hear you i hear
you although uh as many will point out
fracking is a double-edged sword right
you got to talk about the cost of it
which is very substantial and real and
the cost of not doing it because you
don't have access to that energy source
so anyway it's a net net calculation of
course everything is but uh but we are
we are doing great great damage in
places where we do have choices
uh and where uh incentives have been
aligned so as to make it seem like we
have fewer choices than we actually do
yes screening us to make choices that
somebody else wants us to make and even
though it's not in our interest indeed
so um we have of course
uh still and always our our book that we
encourage you to go find and read a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century which is now um out in spanish
and french as well and we'll soon be out
in a number of other languages
we have the chat going on right now if
you're watching live at odyssey and uh
of course any if you are watching later
you can watch on spotify
you can listen on any any place where
podcasts are available we have as of
like this morning a new store
it is still in progress it is still very
much a work in progress but zack if you
want to share
uh just the home screen of the new store
that would be delightful
still there zach
awesome it's a new store and i should
say in the parlance of 19
the late 80s early 90s
it's a much more bitchin store is it i
believe it is i believe it has has many
desirable characteristics
um
upgraded merch
greater diversity it's uh it's an
awesome story and higher and higher
quality too so uh this uh we're not
gonna show you around here but we
encourage you to do so and like we said
it's you know it's still it's still very
much in in beta if you will
but we have here for instance the tour
de france shirt uh which we
rolled out on uh teespring a couple
weeks ago and then the teespring store
promptly went down for you know
presumably unrelated reasons but um here
it is uh better print quality
uh better you know more more choices in
terms of where you might want to put it
it reads what is the what is the line on
the shirt uh
the tour de france it's like bike racing
on steroids yeah yeah
i have wanted to put that on a shirt for
many many years and suddenly what do you
know we have the ability to put things
on shirts suddenly you have the option
and there's also a couple of shirts it
comes with great art too i did not have
the art in mind but we have a marvelous
artist you know we work with yes he's
fabulous uh also we have the youtube
shirt uh that was uh that that teespring
took down but because it is um is it
that it's irony is that why we're
allowed to
oh no i don't think irony would do it
but satire protection satire satire
clearly satire so i don't think youtube
will take it that way no of course not
no uh what does what does it say uh it
says youtube community guidelines
because you can't handle the truth
indeed and then the final uh piece of
merch up there we've got you know these
backpacks there's all sorts of good
stuff up there now there's no
embroidered caps
uh the final one that we actually maybe
never even released or we thought about
but now it's up uh is oh you're gonna
want one of these especially after this
week's show
um it is um
can we show it zach are you able to
access it
yeah
yeah you probably do
yeah uh so uh we'll just sort of
yeah okay if you can show it that's
awesome
so this is a
shirt uh wow that's a tote bag
it's inspired by the uh
the um
above and beyond performance of
pfizer
pfizer the breakthroughs never stop
yep
we said it yep we did right we did
uh and you know maybe actually my
favorite thing on the new store which is
not which is not dangerous is the epic
tabby tote bag oh it's dangerous but at
a very small at the point that we have
one of them we will show you the epic
tabby tote bag with an epic tabby in it
uh the the epic the very epic tabby uh
on which the art uh was designed
for which you modeled here's the thing
we are we are as always working without
a net you and i are both um trained
ethologists
animal behaviorists yes as trained
animal behaviors who know an awful lot
about this individual animal you and i
have both separately predicted that he
is going to like being in the tote bag
absolutely even though many cats would
not no so we'll see we'll see if we've
got that one right if we've understood
the mind of the creature in question i
think you will like it in all of the
orientations
i think you will like it if we leave it
open on its side as most cats would i
think he will leap into it if we leave
it sitting open and upright as some cats
would i think he will even like to be
carried around in it as most cats would
not i think he will enjoy being swung
gently gently and then released and then
he will return from work
yes
and that is part of what makes him so
epic yes indeed okay so uh do go check
out the store uh we're very excited
about it and uh thrilled to be working
with the people at squid print who who
made the store and are are doing all the
work behind the scenes
i love that name too because you have to
you have to make the connection but once
you do
i mean
of course squid print obviously
obviously obviously yeah make it up
uh okay in uh go check out my natural
selections my sub stack uh this week we
i talked a little bit about just a
little vignette from a flower shop that
i had in which uh a woman invited me
into her decision making about which
bouquet to buy and acknowledged when i
asked her directly if the house guests
who were coming for whom she was buying
the bouquet were dear to her you had a
flower shop
what did i say
you dangled a modifier and it sounded
like you had a flower shop that i didn't
know about sorry i didn't mean to
interrupt your story but i'm pretty sure
you you didn't mean that
i'm not sure what i didn't mean now that
you have a flower shop that i'm unaware
of vignette right a vignette i believe i
said vignette you did okay moving on
never mind then um so we are supported
by our audience we are as we already
said we appreciate you subscribing and
liking and sharing
and uh we've got the clips eclipse
channels and the main channels and
um youtube has demonetized us as we've
said
so
we appreciate any and all support that
you can send our way one of those is uh
through our patreons where we have an
active discord community that is uh
that's
that is just terrific apparently we we
don't actually spend time there but
we're thinking of starting to
and it's a concordant discord community
as they all should be but ours
definitely is and what does that mean it
means that uh that they are communal and
they look out for each other and um
and uh discord suggests a battle and all
it does it's true it does yes it does
uh can we go back can we get the
vignette is it possible i could
apologize to you for stepping on your
story and uh no it's in the sub stack if
you're interested you should go there
okay yeah um yeah so
yeah i just i
the little point that i was making there
which i'm now i'm not gonna go back
um
so
as the discord people told us um
you can engage in honest conversations
about difficult topics join a book club
even unwind with virtual happy hours and
karaoke young or old left or right
there's a spot for you around the
campfire at the discord which you can
access by joining either of our patreons
and of course we have sponsors to whom
we are quite quite grateful
and um we actually really do you know we
we are very choosy about who um
who we let into sponsoring dark horse so
without further ado here we go three of
them this week
as usual
all right
our first sponsor today is new to us
it's element that's lmnt element
element is an electrolyte drink mix that
has everything you need and nothing you
don't it's got a lot of salts 1000
milligrams sodium 200 milligrams
potassium 600 milligrams of magnesium
but it has no sugar no coloring no
artificial ingredients no gluten and no
fillers
electrolytes as many of you will know
facilitate hundreds of functions in the
body including the connection of nerve
impulses hormonal regulation and
nutrient absorption
element can help prevent aluminum and
eliminate headaches muscle cramps and
sleeplessness
i have now heard from several friends
independently of one another about how
much they element for themselves or in
some cases for the physically
hard-working men in their lives they
drink it every day and feel better doing
so
when you sweat the primary electrolyte
loss is sodium athletes can lose up to
seven grams per day element is
formulated to help anyone with their
electrolyte needs and is perfectly
suited to folks following a keto or low
carb or paleo diet as well
it's not just for athletes though
element
is useful for anyone being active
even drinking a few glasses of wine can
leave you depleted an element can help
right now element is offering our
listeners a free sample pack with any
purchase and they've got a tremendous
number of very interesting flavors
flavors
that's eight single serving packets free
with any element order this is a great
way to try all eight flavors or share
element with a salty friend
get yours at drinkelement.com darkhorse
this deal is only available through our
link you must go to d-r-i-n-k-l-m-n-t
com darkhorse
element offers no questions when you ask
for a refund
now element offers no questions asked
refunds that's how that reads try it
totally risk free if you don't like it
share it with a salty friend and they
will give you your money back no
questions asked you have nothing to lose
all right
our second sponsor today is public goods
public goods was one of our very first
sponsors in 2021 and we are as pleased
with them now is when we first tried
their products
public goods can simplify your life
they're a one-stop shop for everyday
essentials their ingredients are
carefully sourced high quality and
affordable
public goods says coffee and tea grains
and oils like olive and avocado they've
got castile soap and trash bags and
laundry detergent they have spices and
extracts like vanilla and almond
vinegars and pastas dishware and
glassware there is so much at public
goods to make a meal including the
materials to serve it on
public goods searches the globe to find
clean healthy eco-friendly and
innovative products they care about
health and sustainability public goods
products are largely free of harmful
ingredients and additives and the
ingredients are ethically sourced
so rather than buying from a bunch of
single product brands public goods
members can buy all their premium
essentials in one place with one
beautiful simple streamlined aesthetic
their subscription service is efficient
and easy to use public goods members can
buy all of their premium essentials in
one place so it can become your
everything store
for darkhorse listeners we have the
following offer receive 15 off your
first public goods order with no minimum
purchase they are so confident that you
will absolutely love their products and
come back again and again that they are
giving you fifteen dollars to spend on
your first purchase go to
publicgoods.com darkhorse or use code
darkhorse at checkout that is p u b
p-u-b-l-i-c-g-o-o-d-s
dot com slash dark horse to receive 15
off your first order
all right our final sponsor this week is
eight sleep
good sleep is a game changer as we
discuss in the sleep chapter of a
hunter-gatherer's guide intelligent life
that found its way to earth might be
surprised by a lot of what it found on
our planet but likely not by the fact of
sleep or dreams sleep is necessary
without good sleep we are destined to be
unhealthy and unproductive
yet more than 30 percent of americans
struggle with sleep and temperature is
one of the main reasons it's well known
that individuals and couples who sleep
together often have different optimal
sleep temperatures or do we
you can say that again
eight sleep allows fine-tuned
temperature regulation for both people
having a cool room and a warm bed is a
luxury that aids sleep makes easy to
obtain
or you could have a cool room and a cool
bathroom some people like i was gonna
add live that in there but i thought i
might trip over it but you're right um
the pod pro cover by hsleep is the most
advanced solution on the market for
thermoregulation
you can add the cover to any mattress
and start sleeping as cool as 55 degrees
fahrenheit bur or as hot as
yikes
we don't recommend either extreme but
your mileage may vary the temperature of
the cover will adjust each side of the
bed based on your sleep stages
biometrics and bedroom temperature
reacting dynamically to create the
optimal sleep environment and i will
point out if you have a bedroom that
faces east and warms up in the summer
before you're ready to get up you can
turn it to cool that thing down yeah
eight sleep users fall asleep 32 faster
reduce sleep interruptions by 40 and get
more restful sleep overall and with 30
more deep sleep on average
that restorative sleep will likely help
you with physical recovery hormone
regulation and mental clarity finally
the alarm feature which can wake you
with temperature change and or slight
chest level vibrations is so much
gentler than any standard alarm
we were both a little skeptical and now
we are totally sold we are surprised at
how much we appreciate this bed go to
eight sleep dot com slash darkhorse to
check out the pod pro cover and save 150
bucks at checkout eight sleep ships to
the usa canada and the uk eight sleep
dot com slash dark horse
excellent
all right
now then
you wanted to start
by talking a little bit about what we
are seeing
anecdotally
lacking any
systematic data uh on account of no one
appears to be collecting it or if they
are reporting on it with regard to
uh copenhagen waves yes so it does seem
that somehow the um
the public mind
is not capable of juggling as many
objects at once as it might need to deal
with modernity and one of the things
that seems to have slipped off the radar
is the fact that somehow this pandemic
continues to ebb and flow and are we
have moved on to ukraine and inflation
and all sorts of other
questions
as you point out you and i in our
social circle have seen
an obvious wave of covet now obviously
one social circle could be way off but
the number of people that we've had
report um covet in the last several
weeks i would say is alarming in light
of how rare it was a month and a half
ago let's say
so anecdotally speaking there seems to
be a wave
there also seems to be
a change in the way covid is behaving
several things are evident both from
anecdote and a certain amount of
exploration uh
scientifically speaking
so one thing that we are seeing is the
possibility that covet is moving lower
in the lungs and one thing that you have
seen you and i have seen in our
anecdotal um
uh pool is
that little kids are getting hit and
they're not getting hit with something
very very minor they're getting hit with
something that is not life-threatening
but is definitely debilitating for days
yeah what is the evidence that it's
going lower and lower in the lungs um
zach actually he's oh he's getting me
water getting ice well okay um
it is referenced in
hydrated yeah it is important hydration
is important
i didn't end up with any water so yeah
anyway boy i see no worries um in any
case
there is evidence that it's moving lower
in the lung of course all of these
things are
difficult to ascertain because of the
noise in the data right in other words
we have different variants there's a
question of which variants get a name
whether or not
the you know if you're seeing an
anecdotal wave of a particular variant
and you're seeing disease lower in the
lung if the two things are the same that
requires an awful lot of work of
sequencing to figure out whether a
particular variant is causing that right
but that'll that all presumes that
there's data at all i just haven't seen
anything suggesting lower in the lungs
there is some um
what i will
say is
the reason i wanted to call attention to
this is that the possibility that the
disease is moving lower in the lungs
the
apparent pattern of it moving in the
direction of young healthy
children
has an ominous ring to it because these
are predictions of garrett vandenbosch
and he has predicted other things which
we have yet to see
but should they unfold so let's just be
let's just be precise um
garrett uh predicted increased virulence
in the wake of mass vaccinating with a
leaky vaccine during a pandemic and the
lower in the lungs is uh what you were
taking as evidence of mass virulence or
did he specifically suggest that we were
going to start to see it um infecting
lower he has specifically suggested that
possibility lower in the lungs yes
and more severe disease so both more
infectiousness and more virulence and
the lower in the lungs is a matter of
greater virulence
um
i don't know whether we're seeing uh
thank you an increased death toll
obviously or death toll per case
but
the fact that we are seeing multiple
predictions from a model tells us
something about what we're supposed to
do right any model that successfully
predicts that which other models cannot
should be taken seriously right now it's
possible to get one or maybe even two
predictions right by luck right but the
more of these predictions that manifest
themselves
the greater the likelihood that the
model that generated those predictions
is
overlaps reality in some important way
and i would also point out that there is
an added more subtle
implication here which is because we are
at the beginning of the summer and
seeing these patterns
this virus which a
was thought likely to be seasonal i must
say i doubted the seasonality of it at
first because of its likely laboratory
origin
but it is likely to be seasonal even if
the virus itself is not is indifferent
to season
our behavior as human beings is not
indifferent to season our exposure to
vitamin d our likelihood to be found
outside these are all important facts
and so the fact that we are seeing a
major wave
while the weather is good here in the
northern uh hemisphere says one very
ominous thing which is that were the
weather bad and we corralled indoors and
not being exposed to vitamin d this
might be much much worse and therefore
the disease itself may be that much more
virulent and is partially being kept at
bay by the the weather
what does that mean for what's coming in
the winter that's more complex because
we are seeing this wave and it is
possible that it will generate enough
natural immunity that by the time the
weather corrals us and starts limiting
people's production of vitamin d a we
will gotten a substantial fraction of
the way to herd immunity at least to
these variants and so
one does not want to predict well winter
is going to be worse because if it's
sufficiently aggressive now at
transmission that will reduce
transmission down the road and so it's
possible that it's summer transmission
although it means something ominous
about the underlying viral evolution uh
is is a lucky break because now is when
you would prefer to have it circulate so
that people are better prepared and less
likely to transmit it and when they do
have lower lower uh viral concentration
lower viral concentration when they get
it they will have gotten it with a
lower exposure and be less sick
now yes because because because they
tend to they are more likely to be
outside yeah um
yeah all of
yeah and i lost my train of thought with
regard to what i was going to say in
response to you
um
that all seems
quite
possible i don't i don't know what's
going on in the southern hemisphere yeah
i don't either and part of the problem
with having
a completely unreliable news environment
a journalistic environment that doesn't
work is that it's the a we're not seeing
it properly reported in the northern
hemisphere and so nobody is inspired to
say well what is going on in the global
south and what does it imply and so you
know we're forced to you know to
read something closer to tea leaves you
know and to work from anecdote
um which is unfortunate it's not how
it's supposed to work
yeah
uh
i guess you know we don't have uh
certainty around what makes
some illnesses seasonal although the
the hypothesis that has been put forward
that seems to have the most support for
things like blue and cold
uh are that it is about uh
the length of the days and the warmth of
the days
the two the two obvious contributing
factors to health being uh the more
likely you are to be outside in the
warmth
uh
means that you will be generating more
vitamin d and also um the the melatonin
that we talked about um
many weeks ago
and also that you were just more likely
to be outside in spaces where it's going
to be harder to get infected because
you're in as as you just said
smaller smaller volume spaces in the
winter larger volume spaces which say
usually the outside and the summer
uh you would
so you know this this may be wave this
is a very hard thing to talk about
because we don't have data we only have
anecdote and we it does seem like in the
last two weeks we're seeing this
increase
and in one way you know at the
astronomical level we're exactly at the
beginning of the summer because we now
call summer um between the summer
solstice and the and the fall equinox
but that isn't always how people have
understood what summer is of course you
know like a you know mid-summer's night
dream from shakespeare um has mid-summer
as the longest uh the longest day of the
year the shortest night of the year
which of course is the solstice and that
is also consistent with while it is it
will tend to be warmer in july and
august in many places than may
uh the days are longest in you know june
and the first half of july
so
you know this you might expect regional
differences to the degree that this
virus is in fact
uh has been seasonal and is moving a
seasonal that here in the pacific
northwest for instance really our summer
is just getting started and it's once
again very cool and drippy here but boy
are august perfect and really septembers
are as well whereas for many people in
many parts of at least the united states
by middle of may it feels like full
summer everything is growing everything
is verdant when we lived in michigan
certainly that was the case you know
the universities ended by end of april
because historically you know the
growing season was such that you just
needed to be if this was your work you
need to be on the farm uh for you know
beginning you know really before april
uh but certainly for you know full time
may june july august
and
substantial differences in
heat profile in seasonality and what's
growing when and in therefore when
people are most likely to be outside
should be expected to affect therefore
when the seasonal viruses
and whether or not this one still is is
the question
will be most rampant
several points one there are two factors
in seasonality potentially one is the
virus evolving to take advantage of
opportunities right so there can be
things
um inscribed in the genome of a virus
that might predispose it to um play
games that
work better in one season or another and
for instance just to work better at a
particular temperature
uh
yeah more effective like be more
transmissible outside a body at a
particular temperature yeah perhaps more
tolerant of existing on a surface um
and that you might have likely to
encounter outdoors anyway there are lots
of ways it could evolve that would
provide a bias and then there are ways
in which a virus that was completely
indifferent to
the information about what season it was
would still appear to behave seasonally
because of our shift in behavior which
is radical
um so those are worth separating
um
second thing i wanted to say i think i
forgot to mention
that in our anecdotal sample i will say
there is a strong but not absolute bias
towards people who are at least somewhat
vaccinated with a globe of 19 vaccines
that's true we have seen some people who
are not vaccinated but the number of
people who have been hit with
substantial disease who are vaccinated
is conspicuous
um which you know raises questions which
i guess we'll get to later in the
podcast uh about um efficacy
of the vaccines um and also possible
downsides right which were never
properly accounted for in the fairy tale
that we were given about how these
things were supposed to function the
risk that they would be counter
productive was never described it wasn't
maybe maybe that's a good a good place
to segue here but uh
one thing that is always worth saying
is that specifically the mrna vaccines
but i guess also the adenovirus vectored
vaccines um
the effects of them on the body are
likely to be very similar to the effects
of of the virus itself because of course
uh
you know to the degree that the disease
that coveted as produced by stars kobe 2
is largely about the spike protein what
the mrna vaccines are doing is having
getting your body to produce the spike
protein over and over and over and over
again so it can be hard to tell the
difference and is there a chance that
having been exposed to the spike via a
vaccine upon being exposed to the actual
complete virus you are more likely to
have a response at this point of course
it's possible um i want to
add two
things here a couple couple things one
is i think the better way to do this is
not to say that the two things are very
similar it's to say that there is a
subset of the effects of the virus and
the vaccines there is a subset of the
effects of these things that overlaps
yes that is that which is there
turns out spike protein is a problem in
and of itself right to the extent that
both uh the virus and the vaccines
produce spike protein there will be an
overlap in whatever
uh
whatever counterproductive
physiology follows from that then there
are a lot of things that are not
overlapping right for example
you would expect that which is caused by
lipid nanoparticles to accompany the
mrna vaccines but not covid or the dna
based adenovectored vaccines etc so
there are lots of subsets you know some
big venn diagram of
stuff but the other thing and i must
tell you
i found jonathan cooy's uh recent
podcast um
uh with uh i'm stumbling to find his
twitter handle anyway i'll come back to
it in a second but
uh jonathan cooy's recent podcast
explored
at a level of technical detail that was
very hard to follow i think even even he
had trouble following elements of it
but explored some of the
massive
differences between
the
likely differences that are downstream
of the way these vaccines induce the
production of spike
that suggest that what is circulating in
vaccinated people
is not entirely spiked protein based on
the
the uh
the construction mrna model right that
basically essentially the
pseudo-uridines that were introduced so
pseudo-uradine is something that does
occur naturally nature uses this
mechanism but it uses it very very
sparingly and we have almost no
understanding of what it does and why it
shows up where it is
the manufacturers that basically turned
your cells into a
vaccine factory
used it universally they replaced all
the uracils right and
what i learned from this podcast that i
did not know
is that the ribosomes are not
indifferent to it that actually this in
neither the ribosomes nor the trnas
deal with this as a uracil what happens
is effectively
an unpredictable phenomenon where there
are lots of errors introduced every time
because the ribosome is built around
hitting a uracil and
reading the information this way a
pseudo-uridine has a very different
effect and so so
uh i have not seen this podcast with uh
jj kowi uh but it sounds like in your
venn diagram of the ways that
the vaccines could cause health problems
and the ways that coven cause health
problems there's this venn diagram as
you said and the spike protein affects
the effects from the spike protein are
not entirely overlapping in part because
there's additional spike protein the
pseudo-uridine
spike protein pro created by
pseudo-uridine mrna effects that will
not be found in the original code which
is itself of course a franken virus but
we've now got like a franken a franken
vaccine for a franken virus and
therefore not even the spike protein is
exactly the same right and what's more
again this is not my area of expertise
but
our vaccinologist friends and others
with more
of a molecular focus will correct me if
i'm wrong here but this also makes an
argument in favor of the dna based
vaccines because the dna vaccines will
not have pseudo-uridine in the rna that
results in the encoding of the spike
proteins right
so anyway because there's no uracil in
dna
uh right so the point is
at the point you get to rna it's a
normal rna because the mechanism is
different so if i've got that wrong
somebody will tell me but um certainly
seems i can't see it how it would be
wrong
oh i wanted to add one more thing um
the question and one of the questions
you and i used to pose to students
was why isn't
the solstice the center of the summer
from a weather perspective in other
words why is there this lag in the warm
temperatures why as things seem like
they're getting wonderfully warm and
beautiful to spend time outside
at least in some parts of the country it
really doesn't begin until like early
mid july um are the days already
shortening
right and um so anyway i just wanted to
put a little bit of an answer here which
has to do with the way
you know we're at all about incident
energy yes that was that is what you
would have um but because it is about
the accumulation of the heat in the
ground and the water and the plants
you've got thermal mass right in the
water and the ground
which causes which causes a lag um and
you know you can see the same thing in
the day
right and you feel it so you know if you
probably almost everyone watching or
listening has been in a home that has
been heated with air like central heat
or blowing air and some people may have
been in homes that have been heated
by radiant heat wherein the the mass of
the objects is actually heated usually
floors or radiators and it is it is that
rather than the air itself uh which is
heated and you can really feel a
difference when you're thermostat if
you're in a
like a forced air heated house or a
a house that is heated by blowing air by
by heating the air as opposed to the
stuff
uh the thermostat can say 68 and you can
either feel very very warm or very very
cold and of course there are a lot of
reasons for that but one of the reasons
will be is the structure itself
warm or cold and if you are coming off
of a summer probably your whole
structure is pretty warm and 68 may
actually feel a little warm for you and
if you're coming off the winter 68 may
feel depending on what all of your
proclivities are a little cool because
although the air temperature may be 68
if all the surfaces you're touching are
cooler than that and if they're
basically sucking heat into them as
opposed to emanating heat it's going to
feel cooler to you
i agree with that except i would adjust
the model a little bit it's one thing
when your floor is warm right you are
warming a thermal mass and depending
upon what your floor is made of that
will have various implications but the
point is you never really
get very much heat to the ceiling into
the high parts of the walls right so
it'll be a very stratified
heat whereas if you heat with air it's
inefficient but you do end up heating
all of those surfaces including the
ceiling and things well but but the but
the hot air rises right more quickly
than the you know that that doesn't that
dissipates so that you end up with less
of what you need because um more of the
heating is above the level of your head
well it's of course complex because it
heats the floor above and so you know if
you're in a two-story home yep and so
anyway there's there's a lot going on
but it's the interplay between these
things that you know a a home in which
the surfaces are not heated cools down
very quickly for example
and anyway it it it varies a lot by
building and how you construct it sure
but also my point is by seasonality yeah
and uh and
and you know that that is part of why
you start spending more time outside
after everything around you the earth
the water the houses the structures have
started heating up because there's been
so much
there's just been so much accumulated
sun that the length of the days
is long enough at the solstice and for
the month either side of the solstice
that the night intervening is not
sufficient to fully cool to disappear so
you get an accumulation of heat in in
the in the masses of things uh and
similarly you get a
disaccumulation accumulation of cold
which isn't really a thing but in the
winter right it's just harder and harder
with each passing day
um as the nights get longer and longer
and the days get shorter and shorter to
recoup any of the energy um that you
lose during the long ever colder nights
yep all right so
speaking of covid
uh there is another
yet another paper this one published in
a mainstream place it's still in in
pre-print it's not published it hasn't
even been peer reviewed
but by reputable mainstream academic uh
suggesting that
hold on i want to go here suggesting
that the code vaccines are doing more
harm than good so you can show my screen
here zach
this is um
serious adverse events
it is it is though
uh so
as soon as possible my screen is going
to be shown here it's called
serious adverse events of special
interest following mrna vaccination and
randomized trials
the communicating author is peter doshi
who
boy i think is
uh
editor
i've forgotten now i don't have it in my
notes that are on screen right now
at
i want to say the british medical
journal although i'm not positive about
that are we live yet zach no
nope
okay
um so don't go live on me yet okay i
need to go back and look at something
i don't have it here well i'm just gonna
object and hopefully this comes up on
the screen soon
so the results of this paper
the results in the abstract which is the
summary written by the authors
of of the paper of the research they
have done
pfizer and modernity mrna covet 19
vaccines were associated with an
increased risk of serious adverse events
of special interest with an absolute
risk increase of 10.1 and 15.1 per 10
000 vaccinated over placebo based lines
of 72.6 and 42.2
uh 95 confidence interval et cetera et
cetera
combined the mrna vaccines were
associated with an absolute risk
increase of serious adverse events of
special interest of 12.5 per 10 000 95
confidence interval 2.1 to 22.9
the excess risk of serious adverse
offensive special interest surpassed the
risk reduction for copenhagen
hospitalization relative to the police
relative to the placebo group in both
pfizer and modernity trials 2.3 and 6.4
per 10 000 participants respectively
so in plain english
what they found by going and looking at
the data in the
uh
that that advisor in moderna finally
released
is that the
risks from these vaccines the risks of
serious adverse events and they describe
how those are defined and they're
defined pretty carefully and very much
the same between pfizer and marina
uh the instance of serious adverse
events
is higher than the benefits
from the vaccines as measured by release
reduced reduced uh hospitalizations
that is consistent with all sorts of
things we're seeing of course uh this is
a paper that is due to be published in a
major journal
by a lot of
a lot of big names who are you know have
not been have have not been
de-platformed if not be canceled for
saying such things
and
what this
i guess i'm throwing a little bit
because can you take the screen off off
of me directly bret zach
um
oh my goodness
okay do you want to show my screen then
okay
let's just quickly show the paper if you
can
okay so this this is the paper you can
see they've
put in big grit print across the back
across you know pre-print not
peer-reviewed uh but as we've talked
about before uh you've you've a got what
seven authors on here who effectively
each other's peers who are here
reviewing it and lots of other people
who know what they're doing who have
reviewed this effectively uh but because
most people who aren't scientists hear
peer review as the the super non of what
it means on good science the fact that's
not peer reviewed is going to be used to
uh to
this message dismiss it and the fact is
unable to hear us
all right we're gonna reboot the audio
oh
talking
all right all right we are back so sorry
about that apologies uh tech problems
all over the place um
so
this paper is
uh
new take on somewhat old data it says
much the same thing that many people
have been saying in slightly different
form there has been as far as i've seen
not a peep
in the mainstream media about it
i saw it i don't remember how originally
but then i also saw it covered in phil
harper's substance
and this is robert malone as well okay
robert malone also talked about it
and you know it's this it's the same as
the usual suspects you know including us
talking about these things over and over
and over again and
one has to wonder what why what is going
on so sort of simultaneous with with
this
this being out recently
we have uh zach if you would show
the first i'm gonna ask you to show the
three things that i sent to you we've
got first in washington state wait wait
can we go back and say a thing or two
about this paper if we're gonna move on
well this is all connected but sure um
one thing i want to say is that
inherent to what this paper presents is
a conservatism about the conclusion
right really the conclusion is already
the cost of those vaccinations exceeds
the benefit
the likelihood so because they define
serious adverse events the likelihood
that there is subclinical stuff that has
been caused by these vaccinations but
that has not
unfolded in a serious event yet things
that could be that could remove decades
from people's lives right those things
are very likely to make the picture much
much worse the longer the time period
over which you evaluate them and so
effectively this paper is saying
within a year we have already reached a
level of adverse events that exceeds any
benefit we've seen the chances at the
beginning actually i think it was pfizer
who only tracked it for a month after
one of one of them i don't remember
which one was i think it was fizer that
actually didn't even track for the whole
year they just tracked for a month after
the second dose of the vaccination i
think right um
in any case the point is over a short
period of time the amount of harm done
by the vaccines is already exceeding the
benefit done but because we know the
benefit declines and the harm we don't
know what it does long term but the
chances that it does serious harm and
then none is very very low
so the point is the picture is likely to
be much worse than they present
absolutely so your point i didn't
understand what you meant at first by
conservative here um it is important it
is important for scientists to
convey a conservative interpretation of
their own results uh so that even if
they think they're seeing something
extremely strong uh they stay within the
you know the conservative bounds of what
it might mean which increases the
chances that what they're saying is true
although it may um may well undercell
under describe what is actually true and
so there are at least at least i guess
you've described maybe three ways
that these results here are likely to be
conservative
that
the benefits of the vaccines decline
over time
the costs of the vaccines will increase
over time
and
and therefore a short time period of
measurement
will
appear to make the benefits be higher
than they actually are and also appear
to underweigh the costs
and then you also have what was the
third one
um i can't remember at the moment what
the third way that it was conservative
um
well it's conservative in multiple ways
i think one we didn't mention was
uh that
were you to do an all-cause mortality
over a very long period of time you
would catch lots of little harms that
don't show up in particular adverse
events yeah and actually that's related
to the one i had in my head which i
think you did allude to before which is
that they have specified
in order to be very careful in order to
make it maximally quantitative
uh serious adverse events and that means
that anything that is not designated as
serious or anything that is subclinical
in any way or indeed again this is
related to the first points um anything
that has a delayed effect is unlikely to
be captured here
right and i will also point out that
those of us in the heterodox scientific
and and medical community are very
concerned about the degree to which the
aggressiveness of this campaign
and the focus on vaccinating everybody
irrespective of whether or not their
particular jeopardy suggested it might
be of value to them has the collateral
effect of making it very hard to figure
out how much harm was done by the
vaccines because it makes the control
group that much
smaller and harder to identify right and
that's and that's related to where i was
about to go okay
so in washington state uh zach if you
want to show that first link governor
inslee is mandating that's really tiny
uh mandating vaccines for state
employees
and
this is a story on the washington state
governor's site
july 1st
governor jay inslee has directed his
cabinet agencies to implement policies
to require their employees to be
vaccinated against covert 19
the office of financial management will
begin the process of rulemaking and
engage in bargaining with labor
new mandates in july of 2022 when the
evidence is abundant and ever growing
that these vaccines are not what was
promised and are uh are indeed as the
preprint that we were just discussing
suggests are doing more harm than good
okay
next next link i sent you zach so wait
can i uh
yes pause and suggest something here
in terms of practicality
right we are getting a number of
different signals on a number of
different channels that suggest
something that you and i
uh intuited up front
at the beginning of all of this vaccine
stuff before there was any evidence
which was that the dna based vaccines
were likely to be much safer for various
reasons and so
the fact is if you are in a position
where you are being forced to take
uh one of these vaccines
right you may have a very difficult
choice to make
but
if you were to go with one of the dna
based vaccines the
the
ben article that we discussed
several weeks back suggested that the
dna-based vaccines actually at least so
far show some benefit not all of which
comes from kovid so there's a mystery
about
uh why they might have a positive effect
and that could certainly reverse
ben christine ben as the author
but
we have that piece of evidence we have
what i believe is going to turn out to
be correct which is that the
pseudo uridine
problem will not afflict uh the
the mrnas that result in spike protein
and so anyway a person and you have just
the simple fact that each of the
vaccination
incidents
seems to carry some separate risk and so
a vaccine that requires one dose rather
than two has a benefit there as well so
um we are not giving medical advice but
were we faced with a difficult choice
and we understand that many people were
choosing between vaccines
so far we've seen several independent
reasons to think that probably what
risks exist are reduced in
in the case of those
yep
and in canada zachary we are told two
doses are no longer enough this is in
toronto sun on july 4. canadians now
required to get covered shot every nine
months
ah that sounds like quite
quite a vaccine we got going there uh
how so
uh health minister jean-yves duclos told
reporters so so the toronto sun says if
you thought you were fully vaccinated
think again oh you guys are not seeing
the screen anymore
um now we can we can move on uh and so
and then finally in this little
you know this little trio of okay
governor inslee and washington state
says actually all state employees um
with some limitations need to be
vaccinated canada is saying actually you
got to get boosters every nine months
and um elmo elmo is on it as well so uh
zach if you want to show
uh elmo from sesame street getting
talking about his vaccination status
let's let's do this
yes we do it's the video that we want to
show
all right well um
background information on elmo he's red
i was going to ask you because although
he seems red to me
well and you can see from that little
screenshot that's actually showed us his
dad is also red suggesting
higher certainty of paternity than you
might have otherwise thought we don't
actually know the range of colors within
whatever subspecies of muppet elmo might
oh you think i don't i thought all the
muppets can't interbreed i don't i mean
i guess if kermit and miss piggy right i
mean maybe it was just a tryst i don't
know maybe they we didn't see any little
frog pink babies
right yeah we had pigs oh yeah and then
there's of course haldane's rule the
possibility that the uh were they to
have produced hybrid muppet babies that
the one that was heterogametic would
have been
born
still
would have been infertile or short-lived
oh boy it's tough too with kermit being
a frog and all and the incredibly high
rate of polyploidy in in frogs and you
know just how is that going to work with
your genetic sex determination over here
with mammals and then you're you know
you got
you got a lot of crazy genetics going on
this is the worst frog mix it's worse
than being star-crossed
it's being i don't know felt crossed or
something crust
felt crossed lovers yeah okay well i i
think that was a fine little uh
muppet mating jetix we successfully
avoided dead air goodness um you have
the video to to show our audience now
zach
excellent now daddy has super duper just
just like elmo
you were super duper today getting your
covert vaccine elmo
there was a little pinch but it was okay
emma was really glad to have daddy and
baby david there with him baby david
where are you
i had a lot of questions about elmo
getting the covert vaccine was it safe
was it the right decision
i talked to our pediatrician so i could
make the right choice
i learned that elmo getting vaccinated
is the best way to keep himself our
friends neighbors and everyone else
healthy and enjoying the things they
love oh daddy oh elmo and baby david
have a question
can we have a hug oh come here son uh
everyone loves you daddy i love you too
it's okay to have questions about covet
vaccines for your kids
is that what those are called those
little goatees no that's a goatee that's
just a goatee that's just a goat it's
just a goatee yeah yeah he's looking
pretty hip he's trying to get oh he's
hit the hip dads with their cute red
kids and uh
and just explain to the kids this is
going to keep you safe it's going to
keep your family and friends if it's
going to keep your community safe if you
just get one of these shots which oh
don't pay any attention to the data
behind the curtain uh as you know the
papers and the researchers who are
actually finding that no no
this is not this doesn't stop
transmission and it doesn't stop
infection and although lots of people
like to respond once they're sick by
saying well i'm sure glad i got the shot
because if i hadn't i sure would have
been sicker now on no basis whatsoever
like this seems to be the new like fly
in the ukraine colors in your in your
twitter bio like once you get covered
you're expected to say or a lot of high
profile people say
at least i got boosted at least i got
vaccinated else i'd sure as [ __ ] be
sicker with covid right now how do you
know that yeah it's not true there's
like it has been said it has been said
by people who wear nice lab coats and
look to be authoritative on the matter
but they've never shown us any evidence
of this being true we've got a lot of
people proclaiming it to be true which
by the way is not how science works
no and it is particularly disturbing to
hear this done via elmo and to hear the
particular nonsense about this is the
best way to keep you elmo safe and your
community etc etc because
there was never any implication from
evidence that this made children who
were healthy safer right and so the idea
is this was always about protecting
people who were vulnerable by
vaccinating children at unknown risk
right which was never acceptable
um what what sane rational decent
society does such a thing but we've done
it without explaining that that's what
we're doing now we've put uh this into a
cute muppet
and the whole point the way the thing is
structured the whole idea
is that the child watching their
you know the cutest muppet of all
declaring how proud he is and that his
father did have questions but they were
all answered the song okay to have
questions it's okay as long as you come
to the same answer we have told you to
come to ask all the questions you want
but come to the right answer right if
you come to a different answer then your
right wing right
and those questions were always wrong
right so the point is really using
manipulating i mean this is just like
the ice cream stuff and all of the
various tactics that were used to
manipulate stuff now they offered ice
cream to kids getting vaccinated and
things like that the point is
manipulating children who are of course
in need of protection from adults who
wish to manipulate them for so many
reasons this is adults who are wrong
manipulating children so is to override
the legitimate questions that their
thinking parents might have and the
point is oh well it all ends up with the
parent deciding to vaccinate the child
who doesn't need it because he's a
healthy young muppet you know um so yeah
i guarantee you elmo didn't need it elmo
didn't need it yeah no he's a muppet
he's a muppet um yeah the the only basis
on which elmo
could arguably on the other hand elmo
wasn't harmed by it either on account
he's a muppet well there's that but i'm
also thinking elmo has
got to be
30 or 40.
um he's a pedomorphic muppet right he
has a pedometer and yeah he's stuck in
time
second time okay so anyway the whole
point is that how diabolical is this
that that even at this point at which
any rational person should be able to
look at this and say look overall
safe
no
effective
how
crippled do you have to make that term
before it applies to these
most appallingly ineffective vaccines
right you have to really bend that term
they have to be well it's effective at
something so go get it what is that
something it's not controlling the
pandemic right it's uh it's not
keeping you from giving it to your
family or getting it from them it's you
know at best it's to keep vulnerable
people out of the hospital and they're
giving it to people who aren't
vulnerable right right it's insane
so in light of all of this i wanted to
share
a conversation that i had this week i'm
going to change enough details so as to
fully anonymize the people but
it's two women who i've met before and
they will know that i'm talking about
about them
but they will also see that i have
changed enough details that this uh they
they will remain anonymous
but your identity remains in the open in
this conversation yeah yeah yeah so i'm
walking one of the days that it was
beautiful out this week um actually on
the fourth of july and i was uh i was i
was going
uh to see the parade uh one of the
parades that was happening here
and uh ran into these two lovely women
um i think actually don't know don't
know your guys's ages but i think i
think you're maybe a couple decades
older than us because you've got kids
just you know
a little little younger than us
these women are wide awake
they're liberal and they are not buying
the mainstream media nonsense
they are
both vaccinating against cobin both with
j and j
and uh
they have no intention of getting any
boosters
although in one of their cases their son
said the reason that they got uh
injected the first time was that their
son said actually you can't see your
grandkids unless you get a vaccine
and so she uh
very reluctantly went and got the one
that she perceived to be the the safest
one the j j
um and she was she wishes she hadn't had
to and so the conversation i then had uh
you know when she's telling me this is
she says
i'm kind of an anti-vaxxer from way back
and i raised my eyebrows at her like
really
why
she says well i never took the flu
vaccine for instance
i said well okay but you know the flu
vaccine isn't really a vaccine if if you
think about it you know if we're
defining vaccine really liberally and
these covered vaccines or vaccines the
flu vaccine is vaccine okay but actually
they're kind of cheating when they're
calling these things vaccines and
um
you know anything with really rapidly
fading efficacy such that you need shots
within a year you know canada saying
nine months uh is as actually jj kowi's
insistence and i think he's right when
calling them transfections rather than
vaccines right
i have not heard him say that about flu
no about the code vaccine certainly yes
yes not about flu um so i said okay so
you know a lot of people have been
skeptical about getting the flu vaccine
so i don't think that makes you an
anti-vaxxer and she said okay
um so i was like but you haven't gotten
any vaccines
and she says oh i'm up to date on my
tetanus shot
and she said i got mmr and when i travel
i always get the recommended vaccines
like yellow fever
and
i said well you're hardly an anti-vaxxer
then what you are is a trad boxer
a trad vaxxer
and
i'm also a trad boxer
i think you're also a trad vaxxer and
trad here
obviously has
implications over in like trad wife
space
trad wife hell no neither these women
would abide by that name i certainly
don't hell no
trad vaxxer
referring to what vaccines originally
were the mechanism by which they work
the reason that they are effective in
getting your immune system to become
aware of something in a small way such
that if they become uh infected if if
the body becomes exposed to the actual
virus or whatever the pathogen is in a
larger form it has a head start on it
yeah absolutely as we say in our book
vaccines along with antibiotics and
surgery are three are the three things
in western medicine that western
medicine has the most to be proud of
but that doesn't mean that anything you
slap the label on
vaccine is necessarily a vaccine and so
these trad vacs are that's that's what
she she's an anti-vaxxer he's a trad
boxer yeah i love the term tradvaxer i'm
a little concerned that we're stuck
in that it's not exact the line that one
might draw if one had access to really
good information on which vaccines are
net valuable
i'm not sure that the line is
and i'm not sure how far back it has to
be oh and actually i mean this is
something that i
i wrote out but i'm not going to
go into here but but exactly right that
uh there is no there is no line there's
no time timeline before which and after
which
uh every everything was pure or not
right there there was we we began to
move away from
by virtue of a new platform new
mechanisms of action
what
uh what the early vaccinologists were
doing very quickly and that doesn't mean
that some of those advances weren't
promising
but many of them were dangerous in ways
that because they were incremental or
because the public never was aware of
them
we we just accepted
so
i just want to introduce some of the
necessary nuance here one just because
something works by the traditional
mechanism doesn't mean it's worth the
risk right true so you can have a
cholera fascination
i believe
you already covered this one in in the
past week um yeah but i have not looked
at it i believe that cholera is a fairly
traditional vaccine that is not worth
taking if you are a westerner traveling
into a place that has cholera both
because the efficacy of the color
vaccine is known to be very low and as a
westerner traveling even in very remote
places you are very likely to have
access to clean water which is your best
way to stay clear of cholera to clear it
from your system yep
but
increasingly i am alarmed
by anything that uses killed virus or
fractions of a killed virus because of
the need for adjuvants so although the
killed virus in principle might be in
one way safer than an attenuated virus
because the killed virus can't evolve
um
it is killed virus vaccines are less
likely to infect you with the thing
you're trying to get inoculated against
well killed virus vaccines can't really
infect you right um that counts as less
it's it's a lot less um but
the point is the body doesn't
necessarily react to them
the way it needs to in order to scale up
the immunity because it doesn't read
them as a real infection so it it's more
likely to garbage collect them than to
react to them in a in a way that creates
adaptive immunity so
to beat that they've introduced these
things that annoy the immune system and
make it seem sick so that it reacts as
if it's infected right they create the
create the artificial impression of
something being uh
wrong and they introduce this antigen
and the two of those things come
together and they generate a reaction
but who knows what else they generate a
reaction to who knows how much
autoimmunity who knows how much
food allergy or environmental allergy
might be caused by that
so for my money i'd say
um
uh attenuated vaccines are despite the
scary possibility i mean they do
actually infect us that's how they work
and
that's obviously a risk there's a risk
with every single thing you put in your
body well there's a risk and there's
also probably a cost and i am not
convinced that we know
how big those costs are that we measure
them well in fact the more we learn
about how work is done to see whether
something is
worth
the
um
the hazard the more i'm convinced that
we don't have a system capable of even
giving us good information in this case
what is the distinction you're making
between risk and cost
um for the live attenuated vaccines the
risk is
something that might happen to you right
like
some pathology that might emerge
the cost might be
if you're going to have an attenuated
virus vaccine it's going to infect a
certain number of cells presumably those
cells are ultimately destroyed by the
immune system the immune system learns
the formula in the process of destroying
and discovering the antigens
you've lost some some cells hopefully
they're cells you can afford to lose
right if they're in a tissue that you're
not going to die of the failure of that
tissue then it could very well be worth
it if the disease itself isn't very
serious maybe it's not worth it so 100
of the time there is some cost right and
uh
the vast majority of the time with
effective
uh successful life attenuated vaccines
that cost is relatively minor and the
benefit far outweighs the cost right it
would be hooked um the problem is
because the people doing the testing are
obviously
the people with a perverse incentive
over discovering that wouldn't you know
what these things are safe and hey
they're terrifically effective
or no terrifically efficacious and we
should actually get back to that
distinction
but in any case
the initial vaccine right
generous discovery of the vaccine is
effectively live attenuated right um
because what he used was uh or what he
found was that cowpox had cross
reactivity with smallpox yeah now that's
it's actually perfect so live attenuated
to me sounds like something's been done
to it to make it a little bit less
virulent but it's the sa it's the same
human pathogen but if you've got a
pathogen a sister pathogen
whose host is heterospecific that is to
say different species than humans
that also has cross infectivity that's
perfect right and in fact you know
basically what he noticed as the park
system was that the milkmaids weren't
getting smallpox because they were all
downstream of cow pox right and so it
was attenuated by nature
and that led to the discovery and all of
that and it's a very elegant mechanism
um what to do with all the you know
the i do have a concern
jj cui's point and i'm increasingly
convinced that although i dismissed the
linguistic distinction before i think
this is an error that i made
the transfection question is a serious
one right this is a
um to call this is a vaccine smuggles it
in in a category that feels
safer than it is actually but it's way
safer than some untested technology that
does involve
instead of producing the vaccine in a
factory turning you into a vaccine
factory right that's what it does and
um well and so the linguistic smuggling
yeah uh it almost seems like
even if we weren't actively set up we
were effectively actively set up for
many many years by understanding you
know everyone in polite society is like
oh we know that the anti-vaxxers is just
a different group right and so what that
creates is an understanding that for for
i believe the vast majority of us before
covid would have said yes pro-vaccine
but would i accept anything called a
vaccine if what it actually was was an
experimental medical treatment that
didn't have um the data behind it that
we were being told and whose uh creators
uh had perverse financial incentives
that went deeper than we can ever
imagine most people would have said well
just because you put that label on it
doesn't mean that i'm going to take it
right right and so
this one word and there are a few of
these but the word vaccine has such
cachet as such cache for people um that
it has been that you know even
even now we've got the state of
washington state of washington the prime
minister of canada saying actually no
all y'alls need to be vaccinated and
boosted in all of this even in the face
of increasingly overwhelming evidence
that these
these are not the vaccines you were told
they were right these aren't vaccines at
all
they're transfections i do i don't know
um but i don't see any reason why the
flu vaccine isn't a vaccine i think it's
just a lousy one um
so
maybe there's something i don't know
about it but i think that's i think it
is a vaccine by the mechanistic
definition it's just not uh effective
enough to be worthwhile and has costs
that we don't acknowledge
um
so
i have one other point
it had to do with
the
dna
back the dna transfection
mechanism but i can't remember what it
was anyway um
nonetheless there is something to the
idea that
were you to say you know oh
james is anti-pharmaceutical he's
anti-pill
right that wouldn't make any sense
because presumably james whatever his
conditions might be should be anti just
about every pill and only accept those
for which there's evidence that it would
be more beneficial to him than costly
right and in fact we recognize in the
case of every single
uh
pharmaceutical pill
um that there is toxicity
to it and so
built into the model is
there's a cost and it needs to exceed
that cost
in your particular case well you know
anti-anti-pharmaceutical
uh could be perhaps more accurately for
most of us described as
uh the default position is no thank you
i need to be convinced
that this is going to be valuable for me
that the net benefit outweighs the then
the costs
um that there is net benefit rather and
um
that somehow that position which is an
extraordinarily reasonable and middle of
the road position
has been denounced as anti-scientific
as right-wing
as
as bad for public health as therefore
anti-community-spirited
and it is it is none of these things
elmo and his father not withstanding
right
now this reminds me what i was going to
say
the
there is a hallmark in fact i think
there are several hallmarks of
corruption how much of what we think is
true about x y or z vaccine or
transfection agent is the result of a
corrupt system
one of the hallmarks of it is going to
be the gap between
efficaciousness and effectiveness
right now the distinction between these
things as you know
is that efficacy is
under scientific conditions it's
basically uh in the lab right or during
the trials right
um and effectiveness is empirically in
the world how well does it work so if
you have the trials have ended if it's
been stamped by the fda or whomever um
and now it's just out being used uh by
by gen pop by the general population
then then we are talking effectiveness
right so there are reasons for these two
numbers not to be the same right for
example the difficulty if a protocol is
very effective against a disease but
it's very difficult for a person to
follow you may find people not following
it very well and so the effectiveness
will be lower
on the other hand
that doesn't apply to something like
these transfection agents nope right the
point is it gets administered under the
eyes of an expert
by an expert
and it has its effect or it doesn't and
that's not well i mean actually there is
actually one uh
one thing that we know of aspiration
right
wherein uh presumably although who knows
but in the trials you had people giving
the shots who actually had been trained
for the five minutes they needed to be
trained and how to actually give a shot
which included
aspiration of yeah well that'd be
fascinating if they had been trained to
do it and then we we
there is now ample anecdotal evidence uh
that some number of people uh who seem
to have now be downstream of vaccine
injuries code vaccine injuries
uh had people delivering the shots who
did not know to does it aspirate the
needle i'm not actually sure the
grammatical way to say it uh aspirate
the syringe yeah um
so the reason that this matters is
because
in general if you put the needle in an
arbitrary distance you don't hit a blood
vessel and so whatever you're injecting
goes into the lymph space essentially
and
therefore it has time to infect you know
if it's a if it's a vaccine it has time
to infect the cells right there so it
doesn't just float around the body and
infect cells randomly and frankly making
your arm sick is better than making your
lungs sick for example right
so it matters a lot so if they trained
people in the trials to do this
correctly so the idea is if you happen
to hit a blood vessel and you inject the
thing so the thing is circulating now in
your blood um rather than in the
interstitial space
um that's a hazard because it's not by
design so you want this to be localized
right so if they trained people if they
understood that this needed to be done
correctly in the trial in order to
reduce the number of adverse events in
order for it to actually be an effective
treatment right efficacious treatment
well i mean let's put it this way
there's another
weird phenomenon here is that you're
talking about a respiratory virus and
you're talking about the injection in
the arm and so it's there's a question
about whether that made sense in the
first place but but nonetheless the nose
might have been a more effective vaccine
yeah we didn't have that vaccine but in
any case the um
if you've hit a blood vessel and you
inject it that's bad teaching people to
figure out whether they've hit a blood
vessel before they inject the stuff is
not difficult and the fact that it was
not done and is apparently still not
being done is insane so that was a very
important uh potential difference here
but in any case what i wanted to get at
is
if
pharma games its own trials to make
things look
much more efficacious than they are and
much less hazardous than they are then
what that will look like is a giant gap
between what was reported from the
trials and what we see out in the wild
and of course getting rid of your
uh getting rid of the control group more
generally by vaccinating everybody is
one way to prevent that from happening
but what we are seeing i mean if you're
unblinding the unblinding the trial so
the actual control group ceases to be
um and then trying to vaccinate
everybody irrespective of whether or not
an age stratification makes any argument
whatsoever for vaccinating some of them
is another good way and so what what is
all this well one hallmark of it being
about corruption
is oh
they told me this thing was 90 plus
percent
uh efficacious and its effectiveness is
garbage now they're telling me i need
one every nine months right they're
telling me i need one every nine months
and it doesn't prevent transmission or
contraction of the virus so
what is that gap between oh these things
are stellar and yeah it's garbage you're
gonna need one all the time right that's
a measure of corruption
as is
the
double standard between the various
metrics that are that these new agents
are exposed to versus existing agents
that are repurposed and we should come
back to that another day but
the
um double standard is one hallmark of
corruption and a vast gap between
efficaciousness and effectiveness right
these two technically different things
is going to be another one indeed
all right i think we're done with that
for today yes
you wanted to say a little bit about
uh jordan peterson
and
the actress
actor
ellen i think elliott page yes
uh and how jordan peterson got kicked
off twitter
right so
uh i will say we're catching up to this
story probably much later than most
people in our audience you and i were in
transit and um
i only i think yesterday finally saw the
video that jordan had put out
where he responds to apparently being
suspended from twitter but suspended
with the agreement that he would have to
delete
his tweet about
ellen
slash elliot page
in order to be welcomed back and jordan
said something for which he was mocked
by many people which is that he'd rather
die than delete the tweet now i don't
think
anybody who has been less predictive
than jordan peterson about the
catastrophe of these linguistic games
and their implication for a wider kind
of failure is in any position to
criticize him for saying that because i
know what he's saying he's not saying
i'd rather die than delete a tweet what
he's saying is i know what that implies
right this is somebody this is a hill
i've long seen
most of you could not see this hill
mocked me years ago when i was on this
hill right and i mean this is
metaphorically this is the hill that
i'll die on is is what he's saying well
and he's saying it having correctly you
know he was mocked before for saying hey
bill c-19 is compelled speech right i
won't do it you know i asked him
personally the first time i met him i
said
you know look i got i've got a lot of
trans students
i you know i call them what they asked
me to call them which by the way was
never they
right it was it was never zir it was
always he or she right
um and he said oh i'll i'll call what
they asked me to as so long as they are
making an attempt to present that way
right he's not an unreasonable guy he's
just saying you can't nor is he mean you
can't force me yeah
you can't force me to say stuff right
and forcing me to say stuff is actually
one step down the road
down an authoritarian path that is
actually well understood
and so anyway what he's saying is look
i jordan peterson am
not going to participate in that because
i know what it is as trivial as the
example may seem i know what it is and
i'm not going to be part of that thing
which i have to say
i respect and admire even if i might
make a different choice in his shoes
right because the reason he didn't want
to delete it according to the video uh
is
um that
the way
twit twitter does not explain what it is
that he's done that violates the rules
and he goes through a taxonomy of what
it might be all of it is absurd but you
know there are various things
um but he what he says is
in twitter says
you will delete the tweet and by doing
so acknowledge that you violated the
rule against
harassment or threatening or
whatever it might have been when in fact
what he has done
is
um
speak he is effectively dead named which
is you might notice not illegal right
it's not even
obvious that it is in and of itself a
it's a made-up crime right
and i would point out you and i have
actually
covered this very issue on this podcast
i don't remember exactly when it was
maybe we can figure it out but we talked
about the fact
that um
bradley manning
is now reported by his wikipedia page
and i checked before the podcast it's
still true
bradley manning has been transmuted into
chelsea manning and that has been
imposed on the piece of history in which
he conveyed classified documents to
wikileaks and the point is it says
chelsea manning did it which is um
absurd
but it's even more obviously absurd
when you take bruce slash caitlyn jenner
right caitlyn jenner was not an olympic
award-winning athlete in whenever that
was athalon winner in the men's division
it was was not right and you know this
it's not that sport is the most
important thing that we are fighting for
it is that sport is so obvious it is so
obvious in sport
that men
who transition
uh to calling themselves women and
presenting as women will never be cannot
be
women and if they went through puberty
as men as boys into men
they will always have male
characteristics that do not change no
matter what their circulating androgen
levels change to no matter what so
caitlyn jenner is not an olympic
award-winning athlete bruce jenner
is
those two personas exist in the same
body
right when caitlyn jenner dies bruce
jenner dies and the idea that by saying
bruce jenner you are dead naming really
bruce jenner is dead there's one human
being and they have changed persona and
they have changed the way they present
to the world but it is one human being
yeah and so
a couple things um one
this is clearly true in both of the
cases that you and i are talking about
not only are we talking about a matter
of public record we are talking about
the ability to describe
historical facts right
you cannot
get in the road of people describing
it's not disrespectful to say bradley
manning conveyed
classified documents to wikileaks
was incarcerated right and then
uh
transitioned
under incarceration right there's
nothing disrespectful about that it's
just a simple description of facts and
the idea that dead naming is part of it
a simple description of fact
no this is
beyond orwellian right or maybe it's not
it's hard to get beyond or well but
it's certainly it's pretty solidly
orwellian to tell people oh no you can't
describe things that are just simply
true and matters of record yeah um and i
would point out
wikipedia reports this wrongly the new
york times reported it wrongly in the
bradley manning case rolling stone does
the same thing the point is we are
accepting this
change in the rules that obviously is
incompatible with a functional society
without ever having discussed what the
costs and benefits
of that change are
and that is a warming now i tweeted
something right before our stream
i just simply described bradley
manning's uh
conviction incarceration etc i just
described it factually now my guess is
twitter's not going to do anything about
it right did i deadname chelsea manning
by mentioning that bradley manning
existed and was a he
no and i doubt chelsea manning would say
so but the point is
all of this and uh jordan makes this
point in his video very clearly
the whole point of this is the arbitrary
application of the rules it's not about
the rules the point is we want the right
to get rid of those that we deem trouble
right and so the point is the arbitrary
application is the point
right now maybe they'll come after me
and it's like a it's like a low posted
speed limit in a town that's exactly it
yeah where
uh most people who drive above the speed
limit never get stopped but almost
anyone is at risk of getting stopped
because almost everyone is going what
the speed limit should be
and therefore when you do get pulled
over if you happen to be you know black
or
arab or you know whatever it is in that
time
whatever it is um the police have cover
and you know this is maybe a somewhat
dated
example at this point but um low posted
speed limit rules are are used to
select
used so that you can so that the
authorities can selectively apply them
and in this case the authorities is the
woke mob right exactly now the question
is
this doesn't show up right the beauty of
selective enforcement from the point of
view of authoritarians who
you know aspire to
being petty dictators
is that they are left with discretion
the vagueness of the rules is part of
that
the fact that you aren't told what it is
what you know jordan you know it's a
tweet it's not very long but there are
three potential places in there that
they might have flagged him and they
don't say which it is so he doesn't say
which of them he's acknowledging if he
deletes the thing right so it's vague to
begin with um you're not given
information and there's no venue where
you could go and say you know uh you
know our friend dr rollergater is still
suspended from twitter for
uh
facetiously invoking the idea of a slap
with a glove which is in itself symbolic
as we talked about in our last stream
so
that you know
the point is some people are going to be
exposed to this others will not that's a
feature not a bug that's the point of
the system is to be able to arbitrarily
wield power where you want and to
immunize those that you don't want to to
do this to
which is a mechanism of control and it's
very serious that it gets in our
uh
our
venue for discussing important issues
unfortunately which is of course what
elon musk was uh was animated by in his
pursuit of twitter um to to liberate it
you speak in the past tense well
as far as i know it's on hold um i hope
he revives it and i hope that the the
episode of jordan peterson functions
like the leah thomas episode in swimming
did where it's so obviously insane
that the point is
scales will fall from many eyes over it
the last thing i wanted to say though is
jordan in his um beautifully lit video
um usually lit yes it's marvelously lit
literally yes
very well done production value you're
not talking metaphorically lit
oh it's on fire but it's also
beautifully lit um
anyway he um
he ends up in the trap that we also have
talked about here where he is forced
to explain why something that's
obviously nonsense and
dangerous is nonsense right and so he
finds himself at length in this chair
trying to make it clear enough that
everyone will understand exactly what
absurd thing has taken place and i i i
still believe and i do not know the
mechanism but i still believe
those of us who see this for what it is
have to figure out how to free ourselves
from the obligation of answering the
sophists
right
the fact is
history happens it's messy people may
harbor
mean intent that you cannot prove you
cannot go around prosecuting because you
think you can detect somebody's mean
intent in a particular tweet that's not
how it works right um and so anyway
somehow we have to free ourselves from
the obligation to respond and jordan's
case i don't think he had a choice but
it is interesting you can see if you
just
watch the thing and you listen to him
working hard to explain in you know
in a way that it's clear enough and that
he doesn't trip over any of the
tripwires that have been arrayed around
the place
you know it's pretty clear what's taking
place
nice
all right the last thing that i wanted
to talk about briefly here before we
sign off for the for the week
is
um was prompted by i am
much of the way through but not yet done
with listening to a novel that i'm
finding quite extraordinary
it's called the only woman in the room
by
marie benedict that's a pen name and
it's a fictionalized history uh it's
historical fiction about hedy lamarr
who was an extraordinary woman
and
uh
just let's just go to this example first
by way of
uh introducing the idea that sort of
expanded from this
in it uh in in the book and uh
i assume that this is more or less
accurate i have not gone and sort of
checked it against biographies of
hedy lamarr she's got this awful husband
she's got this uh austrian munitions
dealer
whom she is married to
as a young gorgeous actress but she
can't be an actress anymore when she's
married to him because he says no
and her jewish parents who find her uh
interested in this guy not completely
reviled by him at first say it might be
protective given how much he wants you
it might be protective for you to marry
him because
hitler's right over the border and uh he
this munitions dealer who becomes her
husband
is interested in independent austria in
keeping austria independent of germany
well we all know how that ends up and
uh and the husband of course becomes
more and more controlling as as men of a
certain uh personality type and as men
powerful men
um historically often have been of the
women in their lives
and so she's got you know she's
incredibly wealthy and she's
stunningly gorgeous and also incredibly
brilliant
uh but she's got you know gowns and
jewelry and all the best food and she
has you know all of the amenities
but she's not
allowed to go out by herself and she's
not allowed to pursue
uh the science that actually her father
has has taught her and that she's very
interested in or any or or her acting
which is what she had begun to do one
was excellent at
and so she says uh this the lamar
character in this the book the only
woman in the room she says i wanted for
nothing
but liberty and purpose
and that struck me as
exactly right
that
uh
many people's ideas of what they would
give to people in their care
is a life of leisure uh you know some of
the ideas of heaven are ones in which uh
there is nothing to be done but sit
around idly and eat bon bons that are
brought to you
and in fact
uh it's telling i think that in most of
those cases the people who themselves
are imagining that they are trying to
create a life like that for others do
not want it for themselves they know
that
so this is
often seen with you know powerful men
in acting control over women
it's seen with many kinds of parents
especially modern helicopter parents
enacting you know control which you know
looks like love and protection um
over
over their children
but in fact your children also you know
not babies you know this there's there's
obviously a
a gradient from complete helplessness to
complete
unhelplessness but you don't learn how
to be helpful and useful and do work in
the world and find value from your own
you know productivity or service or
creativity or discovery or whatever it
is whatever it is that you are going to
do to make meaning in the world you
won't discover if you are simply
protected from all things that are
useful
and many parents are doing that now with
their children and also and this is a
this is a little farther afield but many
people who
think of themselves as communists or
communist adjacent imagine a utopia
in which yes everyone has to do some
kind of work but the work you do kind of
doesn't even necessarily have to match
to what you're interested in or what
you're best at just there's a certain
amount of low-level work that needs to
get done
and that will free us all
to to what
to like this this leisure uh that
what people aren't recognizing is
leisure when earned is fantastic
and we can all look forward to it and it
is exactly what
uh what can't what we can use
as a uh
as a reward
as we are working through the parts of
our work that isn't that rewarding
but if it's just leisure all the time it
quickly becomes its own kind of prison
and
i think the thing that is missing
um either intentionally or not from you
know all of these sorts of examples of
people who want to protect
protect others from work is that meaning
is found in work there is like the
for much of us the meaning of life is
actually found in
you know
struggling through figuring out what
problems need to be solved through
discovery through exploration through
creativity through healing through
service to others through protecting
others to a numbered teaching like
they're all sorts leadership there are
all sorts of
verbs that you can invoke here by which
you might actually find meaning but they
all involve work
and being protected from any of that is
actually going to produce quite the
opposite and and then you will enrage
those people who have effectively
captured you because they will say
you're being ungrateful
how dare you not appreciate all i've
done to protect you from ever having to
work
well no actually
there is value in work
this is uh
an error that i think comes from
the path dependency of evolution having
been discovered late in the history of
people
and the reason is that
that's interesting you have
cost
the amount of
energy you have to spend to do something
the amount of time that you have to
spend to do it the amount of suffering
that is involved in doing it
and you have reward which is internally
generated right which is ah i have that
sense of accomplishment uh or i've
earned this time off and i'm going to
savor it whatever it is right
and so
if you are only paying attention
somatically and you notice oh the
glorious thing is what comes after the
suffering and and all of the investment
and wouldn't it be glorious if i mean
first of all we do try to minimize as we
should the amount of suffering and
investment to get to a given level of
reward right i used to tell our students
that
work was a necessary evil i did not mean
that it is in any way desirable to not
work hard but the basic point is if you
have two people who have to work a
different amount to reach the same level
of productivity you want the one who
worked less to produce the same amount
of value not because that
makes you you know not because we're
trying to get to a leisurely state where
no work is involved but because it means
that you actually have room to do
something else that generates more value
and hopefully you know this is why i
rant and rave um to i think nobody's uh
delight about the problem of the idea of
recreation
right that fun
is something you are supposed to have
in
the process of accomplishing something
right and that when you start thinking
that fun is the whole point rather than
fun is the reward to get you to be
active and do something
you invert the system and what we find
out is exactly what you're pointing out
which is that people who have a life
that looks like this often are not you
know
wonderful people they're spoiled brats
or satisfied with their own lives
right it doesn't satisfy you actually it
leaves you it leaves you rudderless yeah
and so
um i don't know how we
cure people of their
understandable but very wrong instinct
about what they think they want
right um but it's important that we do
because you know i mean we thought we've
also talked about the fact
that what happened to us that tossed us
out of a
set of careers in which we knew what we
were supposed to do every day
right um that that
was a you know that was a violent
upheaval
but it did fill life with purpose and
it's not that the life that we had
before hadn't any purpose it had a ton
of it but the point is
figuring out how to navigate in the
world did create
many interesting puzzles and obviously
um the ability to have an impact you
know as people were paying attention to
what we thought about various things it
created a lot of meaning and i think
you know if you pursued
meaning that was
substantial to you then you would find
that all the things that you think you
want without having to work for them are
downstream they would have to be because
for them to be valuable to you you
already have the circuit that will
release those rewards at the point that
you accomplish whatever it is yeah now
that's
that's right
um that's that's very well said i think
people who are pursuing
that thing you know retire before 30
become a millionaire before 30 or
whatever the current number should be to
make that make sense economically
um it's it's begging for a kind of
infantilized life
and um for being unmoored and you know
some some number of people will be able
to
having
effectively and i don't like this
language because i don't like the idea
that our time doesn't belong to us and
we have to buy it back but uh that's
that's very very very backwards and it
sort of emerges with the industrial
revolution
that whole concept
um that we are you know that our labor
is not ours to begin with and our time
is not ours to begin with
uh but certainly in the modern economy
having a certain amount of money allows
you to have access to your time which
should have been yours to begin with
but of course many people
get their time back not by doing that
but by making different choices around
what kinds of things they are going to
be
willing to never have access to you know
not participate in the market economy in
quite the same way
um but have a tremendous amount of
freedom in terms of who they are
beholden to and how they can move around
the world and
how they're able to spend their time
yeah there's a strange kind of communism
in the idea that your time doesn't
belong to you and you're going to have
to to buy it back right because the idea
is well no you're you're working for the
collective you're working for the
economy right right um and it's nonsense
now
i did used to tell students
don't be shy about earning money and
buying back your time now of course my
point to them was not so that you can
squander it on video games my point was
you want as much of your time as
possible so you can do with it something
you value right there's something
dehumanizing
about doing labor the product of which
you care nothing about right if you're
filing somebody else's papers if you're
flipping burgers that you didn't you
know it's not that you've got a recipe
for burgers you're
stuck in some job the consequence of
which is not important to you that's in
its own way a mini tragedy
and to the extent that you can recover
your time and
go do carpentry or art or
you know
think
deep thoughts and convey them or
whatever it is that you find value in
you should do that
because as you you know as you started
with
the the purpose in life is what actually
drives the sort of deep sense of
satisfaction and if you look at what's
happened to virtually everything we talk
in the book about the junkification of
everything right right junk
relationships
um
junk sex junk media food junk media all
that stuff
the point is it's really about a very
superficial thing that just gives you a
little
little charge every now and again rather
than something you know deeply investing
in something and accomplishing it after
a couple of years and feeling that you
know
months of joy at finally having produced
whatever it was yeah so anyway
it's out there but it requires it
requires freeing yourselves from what
the economy will do to you
enough to be able to do what you want to
do
and anyway
if i could wish something for everybody
is that they would have enough um
whatever it is i hate to focus on money
but enough resource and flexibility to
generate that room to do something and
then that you would do it
yeah that's right
all right well i think i think we've
arrived i believe so i believe we've
arrived
still wednesday it is still wednesday
it is going to be wednesday for a little
while longer here on the west coast of
the united states
we are not going to do a q a this week
but when we return to you in a week and
a half on saturday the
16th i believe
we will have a q a then in the meantime
we encourage you to go visit our new
store
darkhorsestore.org pick up some visor
merch some youtube merch tour de france
other things other things there
and
uh you know check out all the things
subscribe to the state of the stations
the channels
like the video if you in fact liked it
share it
comment i guess that helps the algorithm
i hear although like the video and then
like the video
we want them to like the video yes and
then if they like the video in the
modern sense of that term that would be
great too yes yes it would be and share
it and
uh we thank you for
all of the support that we hear from you
and hope that your
if you're in the northern hemisphere
your summer days are going beautifully
so be good to the ones you love eat good
food
and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you